everyone's Andrew I'm on the National
Geographic sea lion and i thought i will
show you my cabin wearing blogging from
this week
to a three foot
and see check it out here is my bag and
my computer i've been blogging in bed
today busy working hard and for all of
you who've been super jealous and wanted
to come with me on this trip look at
that a spare bed in my cabin nobody's
using it and my favorite book in the
whole wide world is right here it is the
National Geographic Alice it's just
sitting right here and I've been poring
over all of these maps plotting my next
moves Central America map what I love
about this cabin is lots of storage
space I can put stuff into the bed I've
got lots of drawers I got clothes in
here I've got my flip-flops and backpack
I keep all my cameras in here bedtime
reading my gps and sunglasses look over
here to the closet here are my life
preservers and say here I got my clothes
and my sandy shoes from today's hiking
in the National Park here's my sink and
what's awesome is this little Lindblad
zodiac lifeboat that I can keep my soap
in like that a lot
and there's me hi and lets you are in my
bathroom which is awesome check out the
shower his hot water
clean up all the dirt from hiking and
then look right there there is the
toilet what's really cool is you can
just come up here and you can pull the
shower curtain across and tint your
shower the best thing of all Gavin is
the view outside
that is what I get to wake up to every
morning